[Music]
we have had the same challenges our
escena spotify and data lock on a
scaling data engineering teams but what
i'm going to talk about what I'm going
to add today is the multi-tenancy
problem that we have in a lavinda so I'm
going to repeat a lot of about all our
tenants and how do we provide data to
them so if you ever have to build a
multi-tenant information infrastructure
you've seen that it's it's probably hard
thing to do
delivering the data tooling in but also
delivering the business value at the
same pace right so how what are the
challenges that we have encountered and
what you will learn what you will take
away in this talk so we have to build a
dismal teeth--and an information
architecture for business insights at
other veinte and we have solved some of
these challenges so this is what I'm
going to explain about today so why me
why why am i explaining this to you so
I've been working in the BI and the data
engineering world since 2011 first as a
consultant but then I entered ships that
at that time as a business intelligence
engineer so and then because we at some
point we have had a lot of data to
process we moved to the data engineering
skill set and capabilities so a little
bit as the same story and in Spotify and
data dock so currently I'm managing a
team of data engineers and data modeler
in other veinte and again to be to build
an analogy with presentation from Walter
we are leading the foundational data
team other veinte so
we are a structure we are an oriental
team and we are a structure to deliver
data to the rest of the organization but
what is a lavinda so a lavinda is a
marketplace as a specialist is where you
go to buy and sell secondhand products
and we have different business around
the world and we help people to match
each other when buying a car finding a
job and moreover we are reducing co2
emissions and we have some reports that
that say that we save 1.5 1.1 million
tons of plastic and twenty point five
million tons of greenhouse gases not
produced because of people not buying
new stuff so these are the brands that
are part of a lavinda
we have more than 30 brands in 16
countries mainly in Europe but also in
South America and North Africa so if you
come from the UK or Germany you probably
know about the spok here in Spain we
have photo Casas and of Italian info
shops Bebo and mil anuncios and coaches
dotnet and you can start to sense the
challenge so how do you provide global
services to this organization that can
they can leverage on the daily basis to
succeed in their local markets we are
here in Barcelona we have this global
services organization we have also some
teams in in Paris and we are responsible
for producing these these global
services from recommendation to
messaging service to a foundational data
service so which is the which is the
problem right as I said
we want to provide fun - '''l data to
our marketplaces because we want to
eliminate the data quality discussions
so imagine also a company like delivery
here hero that explained yesterday a
similar situation we want our
marketplaces to be able to compare
between hims themselves we want to have
the same definition of what a session is
when it comes to clickstream data or we
want to a standardize what when we
consider that an event and not a
classified ad has been created or
deleted so we can compare we can learn
from each other because our marketplaces
are in different states of maturity so
it's very important for them to learn
from each other also from a global
perspective we are requesting a lot of
data to the marketplaces and it takes a
significant amount of time for them to
deliver it back to the central services
so if we can provide tools to minimize
this time then we will have a succeed at
our job and at the end and this is
something that came as a byproduct we
realized that when we were working as
the foundational data team we were
building some libraries some tooling
some data infrastructure that could be
reused by other teams locally but also a
centrally so at the end we are providing
a framework an infrastructure that can
be extended let's take a take a step
back because this could not happen if we
don't fulfill the basics of what an
information architecture need to be a
need to have to succeed as I said I've
been working in another veinte but in
also in smaller companies beforehand
doing bi projects data warehousing
projects data engineering projects and
the first and single topic or think that
we need to succeed is executive support
I've worked in very small teams and
companies that had a executive support
when it comes to building analytics and
building data infrastructure and the
projects were more successful than big
corporate corporations a projects that
had a lot of data but they didn't know
how to extract any value so executive
support is really key in in in this type
of projects second one is to provide
results sooner than later and then
iterate so you can not spend one year or
have even half a year or even a quarter
to deliver value to the organization you
need to provide value after the first
couple of weeks or after the first month
and then you will iterate and you will
fix but it's really important it's
really key that you provide some quick
wins at the very beginning and probably
you will need these quick wins through
time as you go into two-year three-year
initiatives but it's really important to
deliver to the business users and
deliver to your engineering teams
tooling or Dysport or reports or data
that they can use immediately and gather
feedback and then you will improve so
third point is that an information
architecture is not a project some
people see it as a project that you can
start and you can finish but of course
and it may seem obvious right but you
will have some pipeline some things that
you will need to maintain so you need to
form theorem teams you cannot a build a
project that will end and then people
will go and work and dig things that way
wait they were doing beforehand
it's an initiative if you need to
structure around it fourth point is you
need to fix data quality at the source
so we are very tempted to build in our
pipelines or be we built in our code
some edge cases see some people laughing
and when we need them to fix they
request us to fix some use cases or some
problems that the data has in our
pipelines when this is not the way to go
for data engineering at the scale you
need to fix the the data quality issues
at the source otherwise you're going to
be on maintenance mode for a lot of time
without the ability to build on new
things and you will be a stuck last
point is that you need to invest in
solving technical debt throughout the
project so as I said you need to provide
quick wins but then you need to have the
executive support so that you can invest
in solving your technical depth building
libraries that for for those duplicated
code that you have and keep a bit of a
healthy engineering and a code base
right otherwise again you will drown
into your maintenance and bugs and data
quality issues so this was for the basic
information architectures but what
happens when we have a multi-tenant
information architecture what happens
when we want to deliver data and tooling
to our different tenants so for example
think about this foundational data right
so we want to provide session
calculation for 16 different countries
30 different brands how do we do it
another example you want to do user
segmentation on top of your user base
and you want this segmentation to be
more or less a standard and you want to
compare a which type of users to your
brands have so this is another example
of a problem that we have solved and and
that we are we have solved it for a
multi-tenant architecture our and I will
explain more on this by the end so the
challenges that we have faced it is that
we need to find the right level of
authority right a as I said we have
several different tenants but also we
have a global organization that needs
data and reporting so which is the right
level of authority Authority that we
need to have second is how do you govern
the the data sets how do you make people
use the data that you are providing
instead of building their own things and
the third point is which common
infrastructure do you build as a
platform so let's go a little bit in
detail into each one of the three so
about finding the land the lie the right
level of authority so in the authority a
spectrum you can find the sent
decentralized way of working and a
centralized way of working in a
decentralized organization you have all
the authority delegated to your branch
to your marketplaces but in a
centralized organization you have the
authority resides in the central themes
we have been into both actually so when
I joined we were when I joined ships
that at that time that later was
rebranded as a vinta in 2013 we have
silos of unreachable data and I've said
everything so data was unreachable
between the different tenants and
between the global teams so well the
marketplaces were executing fast but
it was difficult to have a global view
and there were a lot of duplication of
efforts so we we saw this and then we
changed the organization's change into a
more centralized kind of kind of
authority but then we had a monolithic
data platform that ended up being a
bottleneck so um the data was a it was
centralized it can work maybe at a
smaller scale but in the scale that we
were at it was very difficult for us and
it was a it was a bottleneck so a little
bit more of detail in the
decentralisation so we have at that time
we had a rational view of the data so we
had several Postgres databases some
brands had the data warehouse etc and
then on the other side the global view
was a corporate corporate PPI
a database that the command the
communication between both of the
systems both of the views was just an
API and this as I said before data silos
are an obvious cause of problems there
is duplication of work there is not a
usability etc etc also there is a global
view but it's very aggravated so you
cannot drill down by any kind of
dimension or metric or anything so when
we move to the other a way of the the
other spectrum of the level of authority
and centralization we had some sources
to ingest and then some consumers and
the idea was nice but then what we built
is a big data platform that it was kind
of a black box that it was very
difficult to use for the different
marketplaces
and it was a slow and a bottleneck for
adoption so which is the right level of
authority we kept some things from this
Big Data Platform actually we kept the
physical storage it's AWS s3 s3 and then
we move to a Federation architecture
what does it means it means that on one
side we have new corporate data sources
like even behavioral tracking or
multiple Kafka systems that were going
to with sending data from the different
marketplaces in real time to the
corporate data like as I said this s3 a
physical storage but then we allowed the
marketplaces to keep running their
businesses and keep having their own
local storages their own local data
warehouses etc but how was the
communication here and how is the
communication nowadays what we have
accomplished so we have accomplished
something that we call downwards
Federation
so all these foundational data all these
core metrics that we have all these
users segmentation is calculated by this
data engineering team globally and then
it's being used by the different
marketplaces so how we do that so the
each regional data warehouse is a
different red shift instance but we are
leveraging to 2ei tools on top of that
so one is Athena and the other one is
Reggie of the spectrum so Athena is good
for central teams to use it's a single
jet even JDBC connection and the central
teams they don't have other data to join
with so they can use Athena it's fast
it's it's actually not expensive at at
our outer scale
and and peopleís is happy because it's
fast and they can access s3 data at a
very low level of granularity and for
our tenants our marketplaces we have
achieved the spectrum installed in their
own redshift clusters that allows us to
provide our global data sources to them
- for analysis or for whatever they want
to use them so in this way we have
solved the issue of the level of
authority so again we have some datasets
that are calculated globally that the
local brands can use because they are
being provided
we are achieve the spectrum and they can
join with their own data sets the second
point how do we do the governance part
then this is really key and it's really
important so we have embraced the
concept of the data sets as products
okay and it's a really interesting
article that you seen in the slides that
you can I encourage you to check later
and this defines that a data set needs
to be discovered discoverable
addressable trustworthy self-describing
interoperable and secure and this way we
you will have achieve a quite good
governance model of the of the data sets
so let's go into a bit of detail into
one of these so for the discoverability
part we have built a search engine for
data sets on top of s3 so and actually
have iterated a bit on that the first
search first search that we had was the
result of indexing all our s3 buckets
and folders this was good at the
beginning but then we didn't have at the
end any kind of governance we could
we could search but we didn't know what
was there actually so we switch it into
kind of a white listing where you
actively have to register your datasets
and you have to provide metadata
information about your datasets to be
able to do so people then later can
request access and and use it so for
example here you can see an example of a
user segmentation data set that you can
search you can apply for access and then
you can start querying the data in s3 or
athina so how do you know all this
information about these data sets so the
data sets need to be addressable so this
means that at some place in in your
documentation in the tool that you're
using for this you need to define which
is the name of the data set which is the
Athena table that you can what you can
find this data and which is the s3 path
where you can find this data so this is
only a part of the documentation of the
data set then we will in in in this
platform you will have a description of
the fields the schema example data etc
but the addressability part is very
important and because this is going to
make your teams more productive because
you will not get interrupted by people
requesting where is this data set in us
in the before before having these people
went into a slag and and they said okay
where I can find this data right so now
we have this all documented and you are
autonomous to a query the data because
you know which data set to request
access how is the table named etc etc so
it has to be also trustworthy and I
explained all that this all the
different brands are in level different
levels of maturity and they are in
different levels of a tracking implement
and it can be that one marketplace has a
better data quality than another
marketplace because of they have not
prioritized the tracking or whatever it
is right so at the end we saw that
people were not using the dashboards or
we're not using the data because they
didn't know if they could trust the data
so what we have added is several
mechanisms to to report in which state
and which quality the data is so we have
a schema validation
we have data quality checks that you can
do in several fields to assess if they
are null or not for example one at one
type but also and the most important one
is that we have provided contextual data
quality information in our visualization
tools so we are using tableau for this
and for example here you can see when
you hover on top of a chart that is
showing the number of session during the
year you can see that this this trend is
reliable so this is very important
because the people is autonomous again
to decide if they want to introduce the
data or not for their data-driven
decisions for the self-describing
aspect as nice I commented before all
that the data set need to include the
data location they need to include the
provenance and if there is any data
mapping you need to include information
about that also we are including example
data how how how often this data is
being generated and executed and how
fresh it is what are the input
preconditions and also and very
important we have Jupiter notebooks for
each one of the data sets where you can
find examples of using this data set so
this has been also very key for adoption
before having that we were just
generating the data set
and the data set was there and then we
hoped people use this data set but we
have realized that we need to put the
example Jupiter notebook in our
definition of don't in our tasks so that
people have this example on how to use
the data set so providing examples on
how to use the data is very good when
you have a multi-tenancy environment for
the interoperable part we had to define
a common nomenclature so this is quite
obvious we had to do it in all the
layers of the of the platform and also
for the schema part for the our terrine
plans and to define the contract between
the marketplaces and our services we are
using we have an ax schema and we are
validating against this a schema and we
are using the schema.org repository to
do that and so for example if you want
to specify which type of an ad do you
have so it's something that you want to
buy or you want to sell or it's a job
offer etc we are providing this set of
values and you have to use one of these
okay because if not the schema validator
validation will not work and it will not
pass it will the event will be there but
some data will be in custom field and it
will be a the quality will not be
unreliable so finally the data set has
to be secure so as I explained in the
very beginning we have this portal where
you can apply for access to a data set
so people is not granted access to
everything when they join the company we
have groups and enrolls that where they
have access to a subset of the data but
then if you want to use a specific data
set for a specific analysis or for a
specific product you need to apply for
access to that data set and actually and
this is because
the GDP our regulation our different
tenants need to provide you the the the
accept or reject for this for this
request right the good thing is that you
can well you can apply on behalf of a
group you can set an expiration date of
these access because if you are doing a
one-week analysis why should you have
access for at eternam to this data set
right and actually this is something
that that GDP is is very it's very
important for us because we want to
comply with GDP our and we have to put
expiration dates to access request and
then you have the rationale so these are
the features that we request to do to
the data sets and this has worked well
for us to be able to provide this data
for the our different tenants and and
they can be autonomous using this data
so finally what common infrastructure we
have built so I explained a little bit
about this search engine this is a
common infrastructure requesting for
access etc but let's go a little bit on
more on detail on the fundamental data
part so how are we solving that problem
so in our team we have sense that when
creating these core matrix for for our
business all metric calculation follows
a pattern and this pattern is the
following so maybe you want to filter
some data beforehand maybe you have to
transform the data before aggregating it
then you have the group by person and
the aggregation function and then maybe
you want to apply some transformation or
we give you the possibility to apply
some transformation at the end of the
aggregation
and also what we have realized is that
our analysts and our business users they
want to calculate all the metrics in all
the possible periods available so not
only what to see what happened yesterday
but also see what happened between
Monday and yesterday between the first
day of the month and yesterday during
the last seven days or during the last
28 days so we are providing frameworks
to to be able to do that very easily so
how does this look in in our in our code
so as you can see here we are defining a
metric ID in this case is counting the
ads with lids we are filtering for lead
events so elitist when a buyer is
contacting a seller to request if the
product is still available or if you can
negotiate the price etc etc so we want
to know we want to aggregate by these
three dimensions and the aggregation
function is count distinct of the @ ID
so in this way we we can know how many
ads ads on a specific period have
received leads and you can see that the
period is not present present here
because it's in our orchestration part
in in Lewisham
but the code is the same for any period
that you want to that you want to
calculate so this configuration is then
passed to this cube function in in a
spark it's a very useful function for us
because it calculates all the subtotals
on all the grand totals for every
permutation of columns so we have
several examples of non aggregate of
aggregate able matrix so we are
calculating all these aggregations and
we are materializing all these
aggregations in industry so that people
can use them
later on and they don't have to
calculate them on their own and actually
if we wouldn't do it like this they
couldn't do it in tableau for example
because the metrics are not agreeable so
at the end the metric calculation system
is very easy you can define a list of
metrics that can be calculated and here
you have several examples for example
you can if you want to calculate how
many sessions you don't need to do any
filter you don't need to do you don't
need to do any filter before not any
filter after it's just account listing
of the session ID field and then the
dimensions are specified in another part
of the code because they are common for
all the metrics that you can find here
so this is a bail up also available also
for other people to use another people
to to take advantage from another
example as I mentioned before is the
user segmentation so we are providing
user segmentation data and user
segmentation functions so that people
can run their own segmentation algorithm
so we are using this error FM's or
recency frequency monetization pattern
and what we are doing here this example
is actually from Jupiter notebook from a
custom example so our fundamental user
segmentation code is different it
doesn't take into account these
variables but if if you are a
marketplace in Chile you can use this
code to calculate your own segmentation
and change the the metrics that you want
to use for the segmentation to be
calculated so in this case we are using
the total number of events and the total
number of sessions to calculate the
monetary part for example it's a very
simple example
it's actually not like this so at the
end this with segment function does
everything for you and we are providing
these to our tenants so that they can
build it on segmentation after that you
can map it the result of this
segmentation and you can specify the
names of the segments as whatever you
want okay so this is also very useful to
provide autonomy to to our teams so what
we have learned during this journey is
that the Federation concept has given us
autonomy has given autonomy globally in
our teams but also has given autonomy to
our marketplaces the noninvasive
governance that we have and this concept
of data status product is has been very
important for us and we are applying it
to each new data set that we are
providing and finally we need to balance
the delivery of the business value
versus the tooling so at the beginning
we were delivering the the matrix
themselves but then we saw okay why
don't we provide also the libraries for
other people to use them so once we had
this this rolling that our stakeholders
have seen that it's also very valuable
for them to have the libraries not only
the the matrix itself so that's it thank
you if you have any questions
thank you for a talk my question was for
example user segmentation might be
useful for operational activity for
example in CRM systems and whose
responsibility would it be to integrate
it from redshift database that is
federated and to get it from there to a
serum CRM system very nice question
we're actually in the in this challenge
at the moment so it's responsible of the
consumer at the moment so for example if
one marketplace wants to automatize the
result of the segmentation - and send it
to a marketing automation tool or CRM or
whatever it's the marketplace owning
that part so we as I said we are just
providing the fundamental data where all
the company agrees with a definition but
then is up to the marketplaces - to use
this data a that being said we have
another team that they are called
enablers team where they help the
marketplaces do this process if they
don't have the resources themselves but
they usually will not end up owning any
kind of cron job or something that sends
this data to CRM etc so for us it's very
important to focus and to keep our focus
on delivering this fundamental core
business and matrix and then the
responsibility is on the marketplace but
globally also we have a some some teams
that can help the marketplaces on that
yes thank you I I've got it why did you
choose to make the dates available in
redshift and zina so we started making
it available in red shift and Athena
because of the visualization part
so all the aggregations that we that we
have we are moving them into redshift
because it's where the data
visualization tools are consuming them
and having a small cluster of redshift
II where I don't know if you have a
hundred people accessing dashboards if
you if you will build this into Athena
every time that you load the dashboard
it will imply some cost some Athena cost
because you will have to do queries etc
etc so for the very aggravated data we
we copy it to redshift so that the data
visualization tools can consume from
from that redshift instance then for the
low level aggregations we are not making
it available in red shift we are only
making it available through Athena so it
depends on the granularity you would go
to Athena or you would go to redshift
thanks thank you for the talk it was
great I wanted to ask you about the
governance part when you say data set is
a product whose product is that is that
completely producer's product or do you
up meant like do you introduce some
responsibility on your site as a data
platform so for example who provides the
the notebooks Jupiter notebooks as
examples so which data products to build
is a responsible at responsibility of
the business so we get the priorities
from the different marketplaces or from
global teams how they have to be built
is also a responsibility of the business
but then owning these core fundamental
data sets it's part of our team and we
do the Jupiter notebook so they have to
be the Jupiter notebook has to be
validated for example for our there has
to be validated by our stakeholders and
the people that has requested that data
set but usually it's us providing it but
there is a validation process
and it can be improved through time by
the people using the data set actually
more specifically what would be the
metadata that the producers provide so
the metadata that the users provide
would be all the filtering options and
by the which dimensions do you need to
aggregate the data for example one
example would be so how do you define
what is a session would be something
that is defined across the company which
events to take into account do sessions
that click from Facebook and then bounce
count as a secession or you have to to
be a specific set of seconds in our
website so this this kind of definitions
are the ones that are agreed upon all
the different tenants and then there is
a our team that centralized the
implementation and provides it to the
rest of the organization
[Music]